well the the divergences are greater
than ever in terms of the disparity in
economic growth and economic and income
and in standards of living if maybe 30
years ago the ratio was six or seven to
one now it's maybe eight or nine to one
so despite huge progress that has been
achieved in Mexico over the last 15
years the fact is that there is a
greater gap between the United States
and Mexico or between Canada the United
States and Mexico then there has been
before and unfortunately that that has
not changed it's getting worse on
immigration nothing really has happened
since 2007 and the issue up to a point
has been laid to rest by the US
recession because some Americans have
the impression that fewer Mexicans are
coming to the US which is probably true
some have the impression that more are
returning to Mexico that's probably not
true but the fact is that once the US
economy picks up again and it will at
some point demand for low-wage low-skill
Mexican labor will return to where it
was a few years ago and we will be back
to 300 350,000 400,000 Mexicans entering
the United States without papers every
year and so the whole immigration issue
will come back to haunt both countries
because they really haven't done
anything to address it
well I think there's two aspects to it
there's the emblematic or symbolic one
which is it's a terrible message to send
to both societies that the United States
wants to build a wall or is building a
wall to try and keep people out orford
mad for that matter to keep things in
like guns or money or chemicals it's a
lousy idea it sends the wrong message
this is not the type of symbol that you
want erected on the border between two
countries that seek to be closer and
closer friends and allies and partners
over the years on the other hand it's
also true that fence is not exactly
being constructed in a huge rush it's
taking forever a very few miles have
actually been built most of the mouths
were where it's been built are
uninhabited I don't think that it is
that much of a big deal I think that too
much was made of it it's as I said for
symbolic reasons but in terms of
actually deterring Mexicans from
entering the United States I don't think
they'll have any effect whatsoever
you